welcome to the Homeroom livestream.
We have a very exciting
conversation planned,
but before we dive into that,
I'll give you my standard announcements.
First of all, just a
reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization
and we wouldn't exist without
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you have the time
and the generosity,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate
and gifts of all sizes
make a huge difference.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
over the last few months.
Khan Academy was running
at a bit of a deficit
even before COVID, and
then you can imagine,
our traffic has been 2 to
3X of what it typically is.
We've been trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs
and content and ways to
support teachers and families,
so special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis
for helping us fill that gap.
But we still are running a
gap, especially for next year.
So any support that can be provided
is very much appreciated.
So, with that, I am very
excited to introduce
our guest, Tom Inglesby,
who's the director of the
Center for Health Security
at Johns Hopkins University.
Good to see you, Tom.
- Great to be with you, Sal.
- So health security seems to be
a very relevant topic right now.
(laughs)
And maybe a good place to start, you know,
I don't want to be flip about
a serious thing, you know,
where are we in your mind
in this COVID journey?
We're obviously six months in.
People, you know, I
remember, back in March,
people kinda like were saying,
maybe it's just going to
be for a month or two,
and then it's back to normal.
Obviously, that hasn't been.
How are you looking at it?
- Yeah, I think, I mean, we're
in the middle, I would say.
We're definitely not through it yet.
I think in some places in the country,
we're probably still at the very beginning
because the number of people who have
antibodies to the disease
is very low in some places,
particularly in counties
that aren't very populous.
In some cities, they've
really gone through it,
like New York city there
are some parts of the city
which have really
experienced terrible disease,
have maybe 40, 50% of the
people have been exposed,
but that's a real exception.
Most of the country hasn't been exposed.
Most of the country is
still susceptible to this,
but the numbers are coming
down slowly in the last month,
and I'm cautiously optimistic
that if we continue to act in this way
and don't completely change your behavior
once September starts that we could keep
moving in this direction until
hopefully we get a vaccine.
- And before we jump into vaccines
and even possible therapies,
I would encourage everyone watching
please put your questions on Facebook
and the YouTube message boards
for both myself and Tom.
I will ask as many of those
questions as possible.
And we're gonna be
talking about, obviously,
this COVID journey, vaccines, therapies,
and also just how does that interface with
how we live our life,
especially in things
like university campuses,
which Tom is also expert on.
Before I even jump into
the vaccine conversation,
you mentioned at the level of
antibodies in the population
being very important.
Obviously, antibodies are
things that can tag pathogens
as they come into the body
so that your immune system
can respond to them.
Does COVID work the way
that many other things do?
I've also read things that,
you know, people might think
that the antibodies might not last,
or they might not be as
robust as necessary to,
even for someone who's had COVID,
you know, they might be
able to get it again.
- We don't know enough
about it yet to say.
I think that's an important,
very important point.
We have some studies that say that
people are protected at
least as long as four months,
but in practice we've seen, so far,
very few repeat infections.
So I think four months,
three to four months,
is probably the minimum for most people.
The maximum level of protection
might be pretty long,
we just don't know yet.
We haven't had enough time to study it.
But it's a great point,
we don't want to give
people the impression
that just because their
antibody test is positive
that they should be fully confident
that they are immune to it.
We don't know that for sure.
We do think it probably
provides protection,
but we don't want to be overly confident
this early in the science of the response.
- But that sounds quite hopeful.
As you mentioned, there's very few cases,
there are a few, but very few
cases of repeat infections,
it seems like, at least four months.
And you know, this is all
about your point earlier
about the antibodies being a
sufficient number of people
having them in a population,
it's all about this herd
immunity at some point
if enough people have it.
So, going on to vaccines,
which is, I guess,
one way of getting
people antibodies faster
or in a broader way,
where do you think we are on that journey?
You know, you hear some places like Russia
and I think we've heard out of China, too,
that they've been administering
some form of a vaccine.
There's talk in the US about
potentially accelerating some of those.
How do you think this
is going to play out?
Do you think what we're
hearing out of Russia or China
is real and credible,
and do you think the US should accelerate
those types of efforts,
or do you think it's gonna
play out slightly slower?
- Yeah, I don't think we should accelerate
what we're doing in the US.
I think it's difficult to know
what's going on in China and Russia
because there's not a whole lot
of information being provided
about how they're using
their vaccine candidates.
I think Russia,
there's a study that's come out
that shows some early
evidence of blood markers
of potential immunity,
but we don't have any real clinical data,
we don't have the results
of clinical trials yet, from Russia,
and the Chinese clinical trials
we know some about,
but we don't know enough about.
So, they're presuming,
if they, in truth, are actually beginning
to vaccinate a lot of people,
that is something we
wouldn't do in the US.
We would proceed more cautiously.
In the US the plan is to, right now,
there are three candidates
that are kind of in the lead
in terms of being furthest along,
and they're all three,
in the middle of large
phase three clinical trials,
which is the important, you know,
kinda final, important phase of a trial.
If those candidates look like
they're safe and effective
at the end of those trials,
that's when we would begin to start
using the vaccine on the public,
but not before that.
It would be unsafe to do that beforehand,
and the US won't do that.
I have confidence that
the US won't do that.
There is pressure on the
system, you can feel it.
If you read the newspaper,
you can see that there is pressure
to move as quickly as we can,
but I do think that
the regulatory agencies
are gonna follow the right path
and make sure the trials are completed
and we know it's safe and effective
before we use the vaccine.
- And I really want to understand,
I want folks listening to understand,
kind of the pros and cons of this.
So where we are with these
three potential vaccines,
and it seems like there's
many coming down the pipeline,
is we're entering phase three.
Phase three is these large-scale tests
to once further validate that
people are getting antibodies,
that they're actually
getting immunity in some form
or protections against the virus,
and that it's also safe.
What do you see as the downsides
of, let's say, you know,
several of these phase three trials,
I believe were already, you know,
several weeks into it or
a month or more into it.
What if they're already seeing,
hey a lot of antibodies,
and we're not seeing people
have some weird side effects,
what is the negative of, of
moving forward with them?
- Well, the negative is that we could,
people could have very
serious adverse reactions
to the vaccine.
I think early on,
these trials will include
up to 30,000 people each.
And we know from other vaccines
that serious reactions from
vaccines can sometimes
occur at a frequency
that's much less common than
one in 30,000 or one in 10,000.
Sometimes the more serious
vaccine side effects
take many people to expose
and so it's really important to be careful
and not to make judgments on the basis
of a few hundred people
or a thousand people,
and to get as much vaccine
safety information as possible.
We also could have a signal
early on that suggests
the vaccine is working,
but when enough people are studied,
it becomes clear that that
was a matter of chance.
And we certainly don't
want to begin to vaccinate
a large number of people with a vaccine
that doesn't work and, or isn't safe.
And so I think there's
pretty strong unanimity
in the public health community
that these trials are
moving along quickly.
Hopefully they will
begin to show the results
over the course of the fall
that show that it's safe and effective.
And then we can get onto
the business of vaccinating,
but we shouldn't be doing that before.
This is a vaccine that will go into
potentially millions, tens of
millions of healthy people.
And so we really gotta
be sure that we know
what's in this vaccine, we know it's safe,
we know it's gonna work before
we move in that direction.
- I mean, it makes, it
makes a ton of sense.
I mean, have there been cases,
I'm sure there are,
coz phase three trials are
designed for this purpose
where things looked pretty promising
at the early parts of
the phase three trial.
And then as you got into month
three or month four of it,
I don't know how long they typically last,
but as you get into
the later stages of it,
they say, "oh, wow,"
you know, "one out of a hundred
people are getting XYZ."
- Yeah, sure.
There've been plenty of
cases where it took some time
before the adverse
effects began to show up.
In the way one good part of trials
or one really important component of it
is something called the data
safety monitoring board,
which has set up at the
beginning of the trial
and which peaks into the
data, somewhere along the way.
And they decide ahead of time.
Once we get our first hundred cases
of COVID in our study participants,
we're gonna peek into the data,
just this small group of people.
And we're going to look at it.
If it looks like the
vaccine is so effective,
that it would be unethical to continue
that it's just, we need to
give this vaccine to people.
It is so incredibly
effective and appears safe.
They'll stop the trial and
that'll be the end of that.
And then we'll move on to,
you know, FDA deliberations
and they'll review the
information, move on.
Similarly, if they look at the data,
the first 100 cases of COVID
that occur in the trial,
and they say, this is really unsafe.
There's a safety signal here.
This is not working as planned.
They'll stop the trial.
So we do have a check along the way
to make sure something isn't
so overwhelmingly favorable
or overwhelmingly unfavorable.
But if it just looks like
the study needs to continue,
it's not at one of those two extremes,
they'll close the data back up.
They won't say a word about any of it,
and they'll let the trial continue.
And then we'll look at the
results when it's completed.
And that probably will
be sometime this fall.
By the time there are enough patients,
for this trial to work, enough
people have to get COVID
and we have to see whether those patients
were people who were vaccinated
or people who are unvaccinated.
- I mean, it makes a ton of sense.
I mean, so what you're saying
is there's a natural mechanism
within the phase three trials
that if something is just looking amazing
and they'll just weigh that against
kind of the public health of not acting,
it's a natural mechanism
that is, you know,
well established in the
scientific community.
It doesn't have to be kind of forced.
- Yeah, it's built in to the trial.
Yeah, absolutely, it's built
in to the trial ahead of time.
They understand, they know the
statistics to ahead of time,
they've thought about it.
So they peek in to the data.
There's a committee, which
is external to the FDA,
it's not part of the companies.
It's a group of highly
respected scientists,
they look at the data together
and they make a judgment
and then they will either stop the trial,
which occasionally does happen.
Something is so overwhelmingly positive
or so dangerous that it will be stopped,
but most likely the trial will continue
and we'll get the results at the end
of the phase three study.
- Very helpful.
There's a lot of questions coming in.
You know, this first
one, I think it may be
as the other side of
what we're talking about.
We're talking about it's
important for us, you know,
to take the time to make sure
that the vaccine is safe.
There's the other side where people might,
we know some people
are afraid of vaccines,
even when it is deemed safe.
So this question from Facebook,
Rosana Ground Intellect Villa floor, says,
is there any possibility that a vaccine
can still make someone sick with COVID-19?
I guess there's two ways
to interpret that question.
Can the vaccine itself make them sick
or can someone who's gotten
the vaccine, later get sick.
And then there's a second question.
Well, let's just say they're,
you know, so what is the mechanism?
I know there's multiple ways
that you can vaccinate someone.
What are the promising candidates
and how are you seeing whether,
you know, the vaccine
itself could make them sick
or will truly be, you
know, 100% protection,
or might it be something
like the flu vaccine
where it's something less than that?
- Yeah, there are number of
different vaccine approaches
that are being pursued.
Some of them use a little bit
of genetic material from the virus.
Some of them use a protein
that the virus creates.
Some of them use an
inactivated form of the virus.
There's different kinds
of approaches to making a vaccine.
And in this case, in terms
of, can it make you sick?
The vaccines that are being used here,
none of them will have a risk
of giving you COVID, none,
but they could have side
effects that make you sick.
That make you feel sick.
Usually, you know, we talk about mild
or moderate side effects from vaccine.
People could have a fever,
they might have a sore arm.
They might feel lousy.
We don't know yet whether
these particular vaccines
will make people feel bad
or how long they might
make people feel bad.
There's usually a range
within the population.
Some people get a bad, you
know, have maybe a fever
and feel badly, some people feel nothing.
So we'll have to see at
the end of the results
of these trials, what
percent of people felt badly
and with what specific symptoms
and we'll get that information
when these trials are completed.
And the second question was related
to remind me Sal, was--
- It's the one, let's say the vaccine
and is what you're saying,
it is gonna be safe.
(indistinct)
We're talking about either
pieces of the RNA of the vaccine
or the proteins that are
produced because of it,
or a kind of killed
version of the vaccine.
So it's not like these are gonna
be live vaccines that can make you sick.
But the second part is so
no one's going to get sick
from the vaccine or get COVID from it.
What's the confidence level that,
you know, is it possible
that we have a vaccine
that gets through phase three,
let's say January or February,
but you know, it's 20%
effective, not 100%.
- So what the FDA has said
is that they would like
at least a 50% effectiveness
for this vaccine.
So they've put that out.
And I'm hopeful that
we'll do better than that,
but 50% effective compared
to what we have now
would be a great benefit in protecting 50%
of the population from the vaccine
would be a huge improvement.
Vaccines have, you
know, have, as you said,
some vaccines are in that range.
The normal flu vaccine could be as low
as that or less in a given year.
But other vaccines that we
have are super effective.
And maybe in the high 90s,
we won't know for this vaccine
until we get through trials
and there may be a big range.
The first vaccine may come
through and it might be 50%.
The second one gets gets
through the system a month later
and it's 80%.
We're gonna not going to
know the answer to that
until we get through the studies.
But even 50% I would say,
it would be something that
would be a real improvement.
The other thing Sal, is that you can,
we should anticipate that
there they're gonna be changes
as more vaccines come online.
As you said before, I
think there's something
on the order of approaching 30 vaccines
that are in human trials
with the big three that are in the lead.
But over the next six months,
we may have a whole number of vaccines
that get through the system
and that are safe and effective,
but have slightly different profiles.
One vaccine may be better
for elderly people.
One vaccine may be restricted for people
who have certain kinds
of underlying conditions.
We just don't know yet.
So we're gonna have to
be somewhat flexible.
The first vaccine might get approved.
And then a second one may come along
and maybe a little bit better
and people wanna switch over,
there number of things that could happen.
- And just to make sure we're this right,
50% efficacy would mean
that 50% of those who get the vaccine
are going to be immune?
Is that what 50% means?
- Yeah, it would be
protected from infection.
It doesn't weight.
There's also another measure of vaccine,
which is, does the vaccine prevent spread
or transmissibility,
which is a second factor,
which we will be looking
at that everyone will be...
The results will help us look at that.
But I think the first
measure that's most important
is does it protect 50% of
people from getting infection?
- I see and then there could
be benefits above and beyond that,
those who still get infected might have
a less severe infection.
They might be less likely
to spread it as well,
which are other things
that you can measure.
- Absolutely, right.
- And so the timeline
that we're looking at,
you know, in a previous live stream,
you know, we had Dr. Fauci on,
we had Bill Gates on
other knowledgeable folks.
You know, we're in this world where
the government has kind of taken a bet
with several companies where we're already
starting the production
of some of these vaccines
while they're in phase three.
So that if we hope that
in January-ish timeframe,
maybe December, January, February,
some of these get through phase three,
there's already some of
that vaccine there for us.
How do you think this could play out,
in kind of our best case scenario?
Let's say one of these first
three candidates are looking,
or maybe hopefully more than one of them
are looking pretty promising.
And we already have that
we've been manufacturing them
for several months.
What's it going to look
like as we go into 2021?
How long before life
becomes somewhat normal?
- Okay, so a couple of thoughts on that,
the first is just how fast are we gonna
be able to get vaccine into people?
And it depends a lot
on when the trials end,
and what combination,
which of the vaccines,
if hopefully more than one, as you said,
get through the system.
Moncef Slaoui, who is the pharma leader
who's been brought into the government
to run Operation Warp Speed
and is focused, you know,
100% on vaccine development
has said that, he's hopeful
that by the end of February,
as many as 40 million Americans
will have been vaccinated.
That's his hope, I'm sure
it could be moved up.
It could be moved back,
depending on what happens on the trials.
That's just one kind of milestone
just to put out there from
someone who's quite knowledgeable
about what's happening.
But even let's say that that is true.
Let's say that there are 40 million people
vaccinated by February,
presumably they will be
people who are at highest risk
from both from their profession
and from their age or
underlying condition.
So that would be 40 million Americans.
Let's say who are in those categories.
That will diminish the risk substantially
for obviously for that group,
if the vaccine is as
effective as we hope it is,
it'll diminish the risk
substantially for that group.
But also it will begin to
diminish mortality for the country
in a way that we can see,
because you know, the people who
are at highest risk of
hospitalization, intubation
and dying from this disease
will begin to be covered first.
No matter what happens though,
no matter how fast we're gonna vaccinate,
we're gonna have to live with this disease
at some level for some time,
because we're not all gonna be able
to be vaccinated at the same time.
Even if all of the vaccines deliver,
there's gonna be over a period of time
that we kind of transition
into vaccination.
There will be some people who
decide not to get vaccinated.
I hope that that number is low
if we do have a safe
and effective vaccine,
because I think the more
that we're vaccinated,
the less likely we're
going to see big outbreaks.
And over time, I think
it will be kind of like
not like a black and white
switch that comes on or off,
but kind of more gray.
Over time the risk of big
outbreaks will begin to decline,
over the course of 2021.
It will depend on the speed of how fast
we're able to manufacture vaccine,
how quickly we're able to
get it into people's arms.
But hopefully our
people's lives will begin
to look closer to normal
over the first half of 2021.
And we'll still have to live
with it in the background.
It'll continue to be
background noise in our lives
I think for a long time,
we're gonna need to continue
to have rapid testing
for people who have symptoms of COVID.
Hopefully there'll be fewer and fewer.
We'll need to isolate
them when they're sick.
We'll need to do many of
the things that we do now,
but they'll just be less frequent.
There'll be less risk overall,
much more ability to return to normal
for most people over time.
- A question here, really
interesting one from Facebook,
Geo Choudry is asking,
is it possible that in the time
it takes to develop a vaccine,
maybe the virus will mutate.
Obviously we have a different,
you know, we have a mutated
version of the flu every year
and we have new vaccines.
Is there something about COVID that
where we don't think this is gonna happen
or it might happen.
- So far the evidence is that
while there are changes to
the virus that are occurring,
there are different
lineages around the world.
The lineages are still
relatively stable enough
that it looks like a vaccine
that works for one will work for all.
So at this point there does not
seem to be any kind of divergence
that will make the vaccines ineffective.
It's a possibility over time.
And it's also a possibility that
getting back to the level of immunity
and how long it lasts,
it's a possibility that
vaccination will be effective
for a period of time,
but that will need to re-vaccinate
in a year or two or three.
We just don't know yet
because we haven't had any time.
So there are different
possibilities in our future,
but so far, the good news is
it looks like the vaccines
that are being created
will work for all lineages,
if they they work.
- So it sounds like an optimistic scenario
would be things start
to somewhat normalize
in the spring, summer of next year.
Although that's kind
of still of optimistic.
That would be if we are
able to get 40 million folks
in the US alone with the vaccines,
you know, the February, March timeframe.
And then obviously you
need to get many more
to get true herd immunity.
And I wanna go...
These conversations always go
a lot faster than I expected.
I definitely want to get to the
idea of school closures and universities,
but the one last question about,
you know, things that make
the virus itself less scary.
You know, the other track
is on the therapeutic side,
you know, how do we make
the virus less deadly,
less likely to do permanent harm to folks?
Where do you see our journey there?
I've heard things like, you know,
some of these anti-inflammatory drugs,
you know, the steroids, you
know, preventing the cytokine.
My wife's a rheumatologist,
so I hear a lot about this.
Where do you see that line of reasoning
going over the next eight, nine months?
So, so far the therapeutic
that's had the greatest benefit
has been oral steroids,
something glucocorticoids or steroids
that the medicines we use
for all sorts of common
inflammatory diseases.
And that's had a pretty
substantial benefit
in people who are intubated,
the sickest people.
It showed as much as a third
reduction in mortality,
which is pretty dramatic for
one medical intervention.
We have an antiviral,
which is from Remdesivir,
which is much smaller benefit.
It's kind of, it's believed at a benefit,
but not as substantial one.
And so far, you know, everything
else is still in trials.
There are antibodies that
are engineered antibodies
that are being studied.
And hopefully we'll know
by the end of the year,
there's a lot of hope that they
might also reduce mortality
perhaps used in combination
with other medicines,
like Remdesivir or Dexamethasone.
So hopeful that those
things will also contribute
to overall lessening mortality.
We're learning things
about the care of patients
in the intensive care unit
about trying to, you know,
either turn them over in a way
that improves their oxygenation
or trying to avoid ventilators
for longer if possible,
because that makes it a
little bit more difficult
to care for people and
to have good outcomes.
So I think if you look at the overall way
that people are cared for,
with this disease in the US
there has been a clear
improvement over time.
And hopefully that will
continue to get better
as we have more things
come through the system.
- But, you know, if I
read between the lines,
it sounds like that's good.
And we have to be doing that
as much of that as possible,
but it's really going to be the vaccine
that will normalize things
unless we have some kind
of unexpected breakthrough
on the therapeutic side.
- Yeah, even if we have a breakthrough
in the therapeutic side that's dramatic,
it's not really going to change
unless it was available to everyone.
And, you know, it's hard
to imagine conditions
in which it would dramatically change
the pattern of spread of the disease.
It could change the outcome
perhaps dramatically,
but not the overall
course of the pandemic.
That's gonna require a vaccine.
- Right, and there's a
world where the you know,
if we had proper therapies,
the disease might not be,
as you know, might be like the flu,
but it sounds like we're far
from that type of situation.
- At this point we are.
- It wouldn't be everyone
wouldn't have access.
So going to the school
opening and closures,
and especially on the university level,
you know, last week we had the chancellor
from University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign on,
and they're doing a very
interesting operation experiment
where they're doing,
the whole campus is getting
tested every three days.
They had developed their own test
where they can get it within
hours, at 24 hours at most.
They're doing really
strong contact tracing.
What do you think about that?
Do you think that is a solution
for the next nine or 10 months?
Or do you think that,
or you will wait and see?
- Well, I think we're going to find out,
hopefully in the next couple of months,
because schools are taking a wide range
of differing approaches
and some schools are really
only testing sick kids
and sick faculty members,
people who clearly have symptoms
and others, like you just said,
are taking kind of the other,
you know, kind of the opposite
pole, testing before arrival
testing one, three, five days
after arrival, a contact tracing.
My instinct is that those
schools with much more testing
and with really close contact tracing
are gonna do much better,
just like in the rest of society,
that's kind of a closed
microcosm of society.
We don't know for sure,
coz this has never been tried,
but I think we will learn hopefully,
you know, in the next month or two.
And so that universities that have taken
a kind of a virtual approach
in the first semester,
hopefully it become pretty
clear what the best practices
are for going in January.
Right now, I think there hasn't been data.
I think the CDC has said they
didn't recommend approach.
They didn't recommend testing
base symptomatics on arrival.
I think many universities have
decided to do that anyway.
And we'll see if it's effective.
And if we have the bandwidth to do that,
that's the other challenge,
is that some universities
have incredible S and T,
science and technology
within the university
and can build those systems
while smaller schools,
they may struggle to be able
to get that kind of testing
that frequency and that,
you know, that extent.
- If you know what I'm
sure you're advising
the leadership at Johns Hopkins,
but if you're a university
president right now,
I guess you have three options,
you can say essentially
pretty much distance learning
or a little bit of hybrid,
but, you know, that's
kind of the safest option.
Option two seems like what
university at Illinois is doing,
which is still, you know, very aggressive
and obviously, you know,
places like Johns Hopkins
obviously have the capacity to do,
I would imagine similar types of things
or, you know, I guess the more lazy fair,
which I already get a sense that,
or maybe not lazy fair,
but you know, just following
the CDC guidelines,
where would you be on,
I guess one of those
first two options is my gut sense
of where you would recommend.
- I think at this point,
just from the initial few weeks
of university experiences,
or even now it's up to
a month in some places
as you know, athletes have come back,
I would lean in favor of really
extensive testing on arrival.
And then with some frequency
over the course of semester.
It may be too much
and maybe we can pull back
from that as we learn more.
But I think there've
been a number of colleges
and universities where we've seen
that doing less is not a good option
and where schools have had to be closed.
Colleges would be closed after
two weeks of being opened
after they've had 100s of new cases.
- And, and so you would...
if you're a university
president you would rather open
and do the aggressive testing than just,
you know, stay distance learning?
(indistinct)
- Yeah, I think at this point,
in terms of overall
virtual versus in person,
I think some parts of the country
have had a community
incidence, which is pretty low,
like for example, many
places in the Northeast,
their overall daily incidents of cases
in that particular city
is somewhere in the order
of three, four, five
cases per day, per 100000.
Other parts of the country,
the incidence of disease is more like
20 or 30 or 40 or 50
cases per day, per 100000.
That's a very dramatic difference.
And so what I hope is
that university towns,
college towns, the communities around them
are able to drive their numbers down
to a low enough incidence
where the arrival of
students is not a threat
and doesn't threat to
kind of be a resurgence
and the town itself isn't
a threat to the students.
The kind of the imbalance.
Right now, I think there are,
if you draw from across the country,
we do have a lot of places right now,
which have very high incidents
and those students, if they're
gonna come across country
to a town, then I think that university
has a real obligation to test them
and make sure that they're not bringing in
kind of higher risk for that community.
So I would say, it's a long answer to say,
in some places, I think
it was reasonable to open
and other places where the
incidence is very high,
it was probably higher risk
and I'm not sure I would have done that.
- Yeah and I realize
we're already out of time,
this is super helpful.
You know, just last thoughts on,
I mean, it sounds like, you know,
we're hopefully all fingers crossed
that the vaccine research,
the phase three trials,
and then the distribution works
over the next six, seven months.
It seems like the most likely scenario.
If you were, you know, emperor
of the universe right now,
would you just be kinda banking on that?
Or are there other things
that you think we could do?
You know, there's some stuff that's maybe
a little bit water under the bridge,
obviously, if we had
better contact tracing,
if we had better testing earlier on,
but are there other
things that we could do
that could give us a more likelihood
of getting to normalcy faster?
- Yeah, I mean, there are
other parts of the world,
which are much closer to normal.
I mean, I would say no country
is acting completely normally now.
And probably every country has
a level of economic downturn
and challenge and societal challenge,
but there are parts of the world
where they've had very few deaths
in the last couple of months,
very few cases in the
last couple of months,
and they're doing the
things that we're doing,
but they're doing them with
more collective buy-in,
with more unity of message.
I think we've just had
kind of a messy six months
where some states have acted one way,
some states have acted another.
We've reopened quickly
and then had to shut down again.
If we kind of continue on what we know,
which is physical distancing,
universal masking,
when you're outside and near other people,
avoiding large gatherings,
basic hand hygiene,
stay home when you're sick,
get tested if you're ill,
do the things we talked
about in this half hour,
I think those things
will go a very long way.
Even if we don't have a vaccine,
I think we can get closer to normal
and other countries have done that.
So I think if we keep
moving in that direction,
even before we have a vaccine,
we'll be doing better.
- Awesome, well, thank you so much, Tom.
This was a super useful update
on where we are in this journey.
It all makes a ton of
sense, thank you for this.
- And thanks for having me, Sal.
- All right.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
I hope you got as much out of
that conversation as I did.
Special thanks to my wife for
cutting my hair yesterday.
It was getting a little bit outlandish,
but it's still looking a little bit odd.
But I also wanna encourage everyone
for joining us tomorrow.
We're gonna have a
conversation about the SAT,
with Dave Travis, who is the leader
of our test prep work on Khan Academy,
for those of y'all who know
where the official practice
alongside the college board for the SAT.
So that's going to be really
interesting to talk about,
all things SAT.
So look forward to that
and I will see you tomorrow.
Everyone, please stay safe
and listen to whatever everything
that Dr. Tom Inglesby just told us.
See you tomorrow, bye bye.
(chime sound)